[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí
y
[Música]
la victoria de petró en colombia el
gobierno de gabriel boric en chile la
posible vuelta de lula da silva en
brasil o la llegada de pedro castillo al
poder en perú latinoamerica amigos se
encuentra inmersa o una vez más en una
enorme ola de cambio político un cambio
que apuesta claramente por el resurgir
de los partidos y los políticos de
izquierdas una nueva izquierda
aparentemente mucho menos radical y
mucho más socialdemócrata que aquella
que conocimos como el llamado socialismo
del siglo 21 pero y si os dijera que
podemos encontrar una pequeña excepción
un pequeño / gigante es que está girando
al camino contrario y que aspira incluso
a convertirse en todo un modelo para el
futuro de la argentina sabréis a quién
me refiero
321 exacto hablamos de uruguay el éxito
de un gobernante no se mide en el
reflejo de un espejo se mide en el
reflejo de cada uno de los uruguayos y
la gente que vive en el país si la gente
se mira al espejo cuando termine nuestro
gobierno y es más libre el gobierno es
exitoso si no lo es habremos fracasado
para mí en lo fundamental luis lacalle
pou presidente de uruguay la historia
que vamos a ver en este vídeo comenzó el
domingo 27 de octubre del 2019 ese día y
tal y como ocurre cada cinco años
tuvieron lugar las elecciones
presidenciales en uruguay y no hablamos
de unas elecciones cualquiera por
primera vez en 15 años se produjo una
alternancia en el poder ese día el
frente amplio la coalición de izquierdas
que llevaba gobernando uruguay desde el
año 2004 fue derrotada una derrota que
para ser justos hay que decir se produjo
por un estrecho estrechísimo margen
fijaos
tras quedar segundo a mucha distancia
del frente amplio en primera vuelta y
con la memoria de las derrotas en
segunda vuelta de su padre en el 2009 y
de él mismo en el 2014 lacalle pou
finalmente se hizo con el poder por un
estrechísimo margen de poco más de punto
y medio apenas 37 mil votos bastaron
para cambiar por completo la política de
uruguay
[Música]
ahora bien que hizo que los votantes
uruguayos decidieran apostar por la
calle pop porque se produjo este cambio
de 180 grados que supone en el contexto
político latinoamericano y quizá es la
pregunta más importante de todas ha
pasado ya tiempo más que suficiente
desde la elección así que la cuestión es
cómo ha cambiado uruguay desde entonces
pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
el nuevo mandato popular
que hizo que la calle pudo llegar al
poder tras 15 años de dominio político
del frente amplio con kepa y se encontró
exactamente el actual presidente de
uruguay queridos amigos amigas para
responder a esta pregunta tenemos que
desplazarnos hasta el año 2019 en ese
tiempo podemos destacar tenéis grandes
temas que preocupaban e incluso
amenazaban el futuro del país en primer
lugar tenemos la cuestión de la
seguridad y es que veréis uruguay ha
sido siempre un país relativamente
seguro sin embargo eso comenzó a cambiar
a partir del año 2011 y en los
siguientes 8 años la tasa de homicidios
prácticamente se duplicó y de repente lo
que nunca había sido una preocupación
relevante la seguridad comenzó a
situarse como uno de los temas claves de
la agenda política la situación estaba
empeorando tanto que incluso algunos
sectores empezaron a pedir que las
fuerzas armadas tomaran el control de la
seguridad interna en detrimento de la
propia policía 3 de febrero de 2019 la
inseguridad el tema que más preocupa a
uruguay de cara a las elecciones
25 de marzo de 2019 preocupación por el
aumento récord de asesinatos y robos
violentos en uruguay los homicidios
crecieron un 45 8% y los robos violentos
un 53 5% en el último año pero eso no
era todo en segundo lugar tras 15 años
de políticas redistributivas del frente
amplio la economía estaba agotada
prácticamente caput
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el crecimiento económico de uruguay pasó
del 46 por ciento en 2013 al crecimiento
en 1 en 2019 la pobreza había comenzado
a crecer y el déficit público se había
disparado hasta prácticamente el 5 por
ciento del pib uno de los mayores
descuadres presupuestarios en toda la
historia de uruguay para colmo las
crecientes regulaciones y la cada vez
mayor intervención del gobierno hicieron
que el país cayera hasta el puesto 101
en el ranking doing business del banco
mundial
[Música]
en otras palabras que el miedo a que la
enfermedad argentina hiciera mella en el
país era algo más que real y por último
tenemos una de las epidemias más comunes
en todos los países hispanos la
corrupción
bueno
para que os hagáis una idea el propio
vice presidente del país raúl sendic fue
acusado de corrupción unas acusaciones
por las que terminó siendo condenado en
2021 inseguridad estancamiento económico
y corrupción tres ingredientes que
juntos significan una cosa de gran
acción institucional si a ver en 2019
uruguay era uno de los mejores países de
latinoamérica en términos económicos
políticos y sociales pero las cosas
simple y llanamente no estaban marchando
por el buen camino y sabéis que justo
ahí apareció la calle pou con un mensaje
muy claro dar un giro de 180 grados a
las políticas del país amigos amigas eso
fue ni más ni menos lo que le permitió
derrotar al frente amplió la promesa de
construir un nuevo uruguay
claro que una cosa es ganar las
elecciones y otra muy pero que muy
distinta a tener un cheque en blanco la
escasa diferencia con la que ganó las
elecciones le ha obligado al gobierno a
depender de una compleja alianza de
cinco partidos para poder alcanzar la
mayoría en el congreso tanto en la
cámara de representantes como en el
senado es la conocida como coalición
multicolor claro que ya os podéis
imaginar que más allá del nombre
mantener a cinco partidos unidos no
siempre resulta una tarea nada fácil
desde luego es algo que te obliga a
tener a todos contentos en otras
palabras que para extractar cualquier
reforma hace falta mucho diálogo y mucha
negociación para colmo llegar al poder
en 2019 y sufrir una pandemia en 2000
mente es cómo decirlo todo una [ __ ]
llegas al poder y al poco tiempo tus
prioridades políticas y económicas
cambian por completo con todo el
gobierno de lacalle pou ha conseguido
introducir importantes cambios en
uruguay cambios radicalmente distintos a
los que se vienen haciendo en
prácticamente todos los países de la
región y que en algunos casos pueden
incluso terminar provocando un enorme
choque político con sus países vecinos
quiere saber exactamente de qué estamos
hablando y cómo está cambiando el país
charrúa pues atentos
reconstruir uruguay
presta mucha atención a la siguiente
noticia uruguay va a más y portugal los
países elegidos por los argentinos por
sus beneficios impositivos
evidentemente uruguay no es ni mucho
menos un paraíso fiscal pero sí que
tiene condiciones mucho mejores que la
argentina sobre todo si las rentas
proceden del exterior y desde luego
sobre todo lo que ha mejorado son las
perspectivas de futuro lo cual podéis
creer me resulta particularmente
importante cuando quieres poner tus
ahorros a buen resguardo no creéis que
queréis que os diga cosas como estas
ayudan y mucho 8 de septiembre del 2020
uruguay aprobó las vacaciones fiscales
por 10 años para los extranjeros que
obtengan la residencia
7 de octubre de 2020 más beneficios en
uruguay lacalle pou aprobó una
flexibilización impositiva para empresas
que se radiquen e inviertan en ese país
ahora bien de todos los procesos de
reforma que el gobierno uruguayo ha
puesto en marcha durante los últimos
años hay uno que destaca por encima del
resto
[Música]
me estoy refiriendo por supuesto a la
conocida como lady urgente consideración
para los amigos hablamos de una
larguísima ley que con
476 artículos ha metido mano en todo
tipo de temas desde la economía hasta la
educación pasando incluso por los
servicios de comunicaciones es el gran
proyecto de transformación del gobierno
y ojo porque tras su aprobación o un
recurso del frente amplio hizo que gran
parte de los cambios tuvieran que ser
sometidos a referéndum y aquí amigos de
nuevo los uruguayos y de nuevo por una
estrecho margen de apenas dos puntos
votaron a favor de las reformas el
ejecutivo uruguayo sale reforzado tras
un referéndum que mantiene al país
dividido
uruguay con estrecho margen el gobierno
gana referendo clave para su gestión por
sólo 22 mil votos de diferencia la
mayoría de los uruguayos respaldo la
opción para no derogar 135 de 476
artículos de la denominada 'ley de
urgente consideración impulsada por el
presidente luis lacalle pou pero ahora
bien que es exactamente lo que dice esta
luz cuáles son sus cambios más
destacados pues entre las principales
reformas podemos encontrar las
siguientes
en materia económica se ha fijado un
límite máximo al crecimiento del gasto
público y un límite al nivel de deuda
así como la creación de un consejo
fiscal para evaluar los diferentes
proyectos de gasto público e intentar
evitar derroches políticos luego en
materia del trabajo a partir de ahora
cuando se produzca una jornada de huelga
se reconocerá expresamente el derecho
tanto de empresarios como de
trabajadores a trabajar si así lo desean
y es que hasta ahora aún con trabajador
no quisiera atenerse a la huelga la
conocida como libertad sindical pasiva
del año 2006 debía impedirle trabajar
ese día en la misma línea a la luz
también declara ilegítimos e ilegales
los dos piquetes que impidan la libre
circulación de personas bienes o
servicios tanto en espacios públicos
como privados es decir que puedes
ponerte en huelga pero no podrás obligar
a otros a que la secunden ni tampoco
podrás parar el país
luego en términos de seguridad la ley
amplía las circunstancias y los lugares
en los que tanto civiles como policías
pueden recurrir a la legítima defensa y
en términos de vivienda se introduce un
nuevo régimen de alquiler voluntario que
reduce los derechos de los inquilinos
este régimen reconoce por ejemplo los
desalojos más rápidos en caso de impagos
la idea es que más propietarios a que en
sus inmuebles al mercado y esto haga
bajar los precios
[Música]
estos son tan sólo algunos de los muchos
cambios con los que el gobierno de
lacalle pou quiere dar un golpe de timón
al rumbo de uruguay ahora el siguiente
paso parece ser la peliaguda reforma de
la seguridad social después de que en el
año 2020 una comisión de expertos
confirmará lo que era un secreto a voces
que con el envejecimiento de la
población y el sistema público de la
seguridad social tal y como está montado
en uruguay es inviable para que os
hagáis una idea del gasto de seguridad
social del país charrúa es similar al de
españa y más elevado que el de países
tan ricos como dinamarca o noruega así
que claro toca ponerse en manos a la
obra' en fin con todo esto que hemos
visto que queréis que os diga te podrán
gustar más o menos las reformas pero
amigos amigas creo que una cosa está muy
clara no se parecen en nada a lo que
está ocurriendo en el resto de américa
latina pero espera hace un momento que
no hemos terminado otra apuesta clave
fundamental y completamente destructiva
de este gobierno tiene mucho que ver con
la política exterior y sobre todo con
mercosur hablamos de una apuesta que
puede terminar ni más ni menos que
haciendo que montevideo mande a la porra
buenos aires y a brasilia atentos
[Música]
un nuevo camino al mundo
fijaos en toda esta declaración de
intenciones
el deber mío como uruguayo es decir
abren el mundo y nos abren el mundo
vamos a andar bien seguro luis lacalle
pou presidente de uruguay amigos amigas
desde que llegó al poder la calle pou
que entendió que hay algo que no
funciona en esta región del mundo algo
por encima del resto de temas algo de lo
que hemos hablado muchas veces aquí en
visual político si me estoy refiriendo a
la política de sustitución de
importaciones y el proteccionismo
galopante que caracteriza a estos países
así que dicho y hecho para disgusto de
la argentina luego entenderéis porque
nada más llegar al poder al gobierno de
uruguay se le metió entre ceja y ceja
lidiar con tres importantes caballos de
batalla en su política exterior primero
hacer que ésta sea más pro mercado
segundo que contribuya a flexibilizar el
mercosur y tercero que facilite la
llegada al país de más inversión
extranjera directa bueno eso y también
poner tierra de por medio con todas las
satrapías populistas de la región es
decir condenar claramente a los
regímenes de cuba nicaragua y venezuela
pero no nos desviemos centrémonos en lo
que está siendo la gran apuesta en
materia exterior del gobierno uruguayo
fijaos uruguay necesita abrirse al mundo
si nos acompañan bien si no vamos solos
luis lacalle pou presidente de uruguay y
estamos en el barco hay que pensar quién
es la carga queremos seguir adelante y
lo vamos a hacer en uruguay estamos
tratando de negociar con china turquía
con el reino unido- luis lacalle pou
presidente de uruguay más claro agua el
actual gobierno charrúa tiene claro que
para lograr más inversiones y más
crecimiento económico el país tiene que
abrirse al mundo el problema es que al
mismo tiempo que quiere negociar nuevos
acuerdos comerciales uruguay pertenece
al mercosur y eso limita mucho su margen
de maniobra que es precisamente lo que
explica noticias como esta la rebeldía
de uruguay tensa al máximo mercosur os
lo hemos contado también aquí en visual
político el mercado común del sur
mercosur no funciona no al menos como
debería se supone que esta institución
tenía el objetivo de promover el
comercio en américa del sur sin embargo
con un arancel externo común que más que
duplica el promedio mundial y muchas
limitaciones a la hora de negociar con
terceros países en la práctica este
acuerdo funciona más bien como una
barrera accionista y por eso el gobierno
de lacalle pou se ha lanzado a toda una
guerra política para conseguir que el
bloque sea más flexible para que se
reduzca ese arancel externo común y para
que los países miembros puedan negociar
acuerdos comerciales con terceros países
por su cuenta algo que la regulación
actual de mercosur impiden
claro que hasta el momento los
resultados no han sido nada positivos
sobre todo buenos aires- sigue
empecinado en que este bloque sea
exactamente lo que es hoy en día una
especie de caja cerrada que en lugar de
alentar el comercio los trending en fin
ya sabéis la energía que los políticos
argentinos le tienen al libre comercio y
la globalización por ejemplo la falta de
interés real en sacar adelante el
acuerdo de libre comercio con la unión
europea es una buena prueba de ello
ahora bien aquí la cuestión es que
uruguay está cerca de firmar un acuerdo
de libre comercio con china y
probablemente también con otros países y
tan sólo china pese a llamarse la cesta
de exportaciones de uruguay que sus
vecinos de mercosur quiere decir esto
que el país charrúa podría terminar
abandonando mercosur hoy por hoy no
parece algo fácil porque todavía sus
socios del bloque dominan las
importaciones pero amigos amigas y las
cosas siguen por este camino en el
futuro no sería algo descartable el
mundo es mucho pero que mucho más grande
que mercosur de hecho del 2019 el peso
de las exportaciones en el pib del país
que venía cayendo desde el 2014 ha
comenzado a crecer de nuevo y en 2021
aunque el saldo exterior siguió siendo
negativo este tuvo su segundo menor
nivel de los últimos 12 años solo fue
mejorado por el dato extraordinario del
2020 cuando las importaciones después
colapsaron con la pandemia
[Música]
y qué significa esto pues que toda esta
historia no se trata solo de un simple
empecinamiento del presidente lo cierto
es que el mercado exterior le está
viniendo muy pero que muy bien a uruguay
y de hecho las exportaciones se
dispararon en 2021 y lo están haciendo
también en 2022 y ahora además la crisis
alimentaria mundial que ha provocado la
invasión rusa de ucrania promete
impulsar aún más las exportaciones y de
llevarse a cabo los planes de lacalle
pou que está claro meridiano que el
sector exterior jugaría un papel clave
en el futuro económico de uruguay así
que como veis el camino pues parece
marcado resumiendo a pesar de la
pandemia la economía ha mejorado el
desempleo está a punto de batir su mejor
registro en siete años la pobreza se
está contrayendo y los delitos se han
reducido sustancialmente
queda mucho por hacer pero los datos son
muy claros hoy por hoy las cosas en
uruguay parece que marchan por buen
camino al menos por un camino mejor que
el que transitaban en 2019 y eso en una
región atestado de problemas es todo un
soplo de aire fresco esto es quizá es lo
que explica que uruguay esté siendo
prácticamente la única excepción al giro
a la izquierda que está experimentando
toda américa latina la pregunta ahora es
pueden las reformas impulsadas por
lacalle pou convertirse en un modelo
para países como la argentina hasta
donde llegarán los cambios impulsados
por el actual presidente de uruguay
revalidar a los uruguayos estás en las
reformas en las próximas elecciones de
2024 amigos amigas estas son las
preguntas y en este caso vuestras las
respuestas si os parece podéis dejarnos
por los comentarios vuestras impresiones
y así podemos abrir debate y como
siempre si éste vídeos ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al aek y
suscribiros abisal político una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]